a big mistake that we make as
entrepreneurs as we think that we've got
to build everything ourselves you're
spending your time on things that you
think are important but are actually
preventing you from being the Michael
Jordan of your industry recognizing my
weaknesses is just as important as
recognizing my strengths and my core
competencies rise and shine it's
expresso time what's up belief nation
it's Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right together grab your
coffee and sip on today's message focus
on what you're good at over to you Mel
Robbins also if you want to know what
Mel Robbins and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the length of join is in
the description below everybody's
problem comes down to one pattern you're
repeating that you can't see when you
set goals when you have an intention on
something that you want to change about
your life your brain helps you and if
you're somebody that's watching this and
you have no clue what you want I'm gonna
say that's total bull
[Music]
a big mistake that we make as
entrepreneurs as we think that we've got
to build everything ourselves and what's
super cool about business today is that
there are channels where you can make
money so that you don't have to do
things that are outside your core
expertise you're a photographer you're
amazing at it
you're a networker I can already tell
you're amazing at it what you should
never ever do is spend time building a
stock photography site because that is
not your core capability but if you just
focus on taking photos which you love
and you upload the stuff that you're not
going to monetize some other way to a
stock photography site as long as it's
not other you know it's not as long as
you know you've got the rights to it in
everything else you can make money on
that stuff all day long and in fact
because so many people are creating
content the stock photography sites have
exploded it's not just Getty and stock
lists and some of the other ones that a
ton of people use there there are tons
of them out there and so that's one
thing that you should be doing where
else do you want to grow your business I
want to make sure I'm able to do that
first step very well before I progress
onto the next in the next phase okay I
don't want to do so many different
things that I'm not doing each one of
them very well that's right so anything
where you're gonna have to learn a new
skill and somebody else has done it and
you can outsource it just like uploading
to stock sites that is you don't want to
make the mistake of having your
attention go off the ball which is
creating a big library of photos and
building something that you have no
interest in building you aren't getting
your big breakthrough yet because you
are not good enough yet and that's
because you are not spending enough time
on the thing that will actually make you
great you're spending your time on
things that you think are important but
are actually preventing you from being
the Michael Jordan of your industry if
you can't flip that switch if you can't
make the move to spending most of your
time on the thing that you can be great
at then you will never be great and you
will be stuck on the hamster wheel of
life working your face off working every
single day but feeling like you're not
going anywhere
so I had a singer recently come and pop
by my studio from my morning sir Graham
live show and she was a very talented
insanely great singer but the challenge
in making the songs was she would spend
30 minutes on actually making the song
and then two hours in post-production
editing and cutting things in and
flipping from one screen to the other
where she's learning the skills that
make for a final product that is better
right now than if she was just singing
but she's not learning the skills that
she needs to learn to get better at her
craft and so here's what she should be
doing here's the advice that I gave her
and she should be taking if you have two
and a half hours to spend you should
learn how to sing a near-perfect song
and spend all of those two and a half
hours
singing because I'm coming to you not
because you're the world's greatest
editor and you don't have ambitions to
be the world's greatest editor and so
you want to spend as much time as
possible singing because learning how to
do multiple takes and crunch those down
to ideally one take or two takes or five
takes instead of 500 takes the editing
is saving you the editing is actually
making you lazy at the skills that you
want to get better at because if you
could take the intro of one song and
then the middle of another song and in
the ending of another song and piece it
together to make it sound like one song
the editing is saving you but you're
actually being lazy at your craft and if
you're spending two hours editing you're
getting better at a skill that you don't
care about and only half an hour at the
skill that you actually want to get good
at and so stop worrying about the
editing stop worrying about the skill
that you do want to get great at and
instead focus in on spending two and a
half hours making each song just two
vocals in one take with zero editing
because learning that skill will serve
her for life and so let's apply that
logic to your business in your situation
I'm gonna give you a three step process
to go through step number one find the
skill that you want to be great at what
is the skill that you have Michael
Jordan potential with what is the skill
that you want to be among the best in
the world
I identify it label it make a commitment
a dedication a proclamation that I want
to be one of the world's greatest acts
of all time step two take daily action
if you are not practiced
the dealy you will never become great if
you only tried to tie your shoe
once a week you would never learn how to
tie your shoe and so don't think that if
you want to be a singer and you're
making a video once every week or every
two weeks so you're ever gonna get good
at it you're just not gonna get
world-class you might have some natural
talent that you can lean back on and be
an OK karaoke singer but you're never
gonna be world-class if you're only
practicing once a week daily you need to
figure out a way how to go daily in your
life I create the Flex the X flex CX get
your calendar out and for every day that
you do it you mark an X can you see can
you see every day that you do it X X X X
I'm going to practice my singing I'm
gonna be world-class at this flex the X
cross it off you've done that work every
single day to get better and then step
number three is your ultimate goals to
get so good at something you start
making money that you can hire for your
weaknesses instead of you learning how
to be a world-class
editor you get so good at your thing
that you start bringing in some money so
momentum that then you can hire the
editor who wants to be the Michael
Jordan of editing that's how you
ultimately will grow and in the
meanwhile until you can get to that
point having acceptable losses
that if you're making videos if you're a
singer and you're just singing into a
microphone in the camera and there's no
editing that that will be a small loss
that your videos will not look as fancy
as other people's videos but it's not
the skill that you want to work on right
now you need to get amazing so that I
can just come and listen to your voice
and be wow it's the greatest singer of
all time who is this person to get there
you have to practice I need you start
building momentum then you put it into
your team then you start building then
you start growing having acceptable
losses now I've got a really special
bonus clip that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that question of the
day I want to know what is the number
one skill that you want to be
world-class at you want to be the
Michael Jordan of let me know put it
down in the comments below
support is knowing your strengths and
weaknesses and knowing what you enjoy
doing you know if you look at it as a
job you've already lost it it's not
going to be your passion and you're
going to count the hours if you look at
it as something you love to do and then
you know what your strengths are then
you can leverage those strengths in your
business and in helping others and once
you recognize your weaknesses then you
can work with people that compliment you
I mean every one of my businesses I've
had a partner who's very anal Martin
Woodall Todd Wagner I mean incredibly
anal people perfectionist because I'm a
slob you know I'm a big-picture think
about what's around the corner how is
technology gonna change things how can I
change you know this industry and you
know making sure that there's somebody
there to make to dot the i's cross the
t's and keep me in the bass lines and
you know recognizing my weaknesses is
just as important as recognizing my
strengths my core competencies and and
you know having a passion to do if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon if
you want more mail check out the top
fifty rules video I made on her the link
is right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there our minds are designed to
stop you at all costs from doing
anything that might hurt you